künstliche intelligenz ki ist ein
riesiges risiko und ziemlich leicht zu
manipulieren und sie kann wiederum
leicht manipulieren sogar sprach
steuerungssysteme wie alexa können
missbraucht werden und bilderkennung
vollkommen in die irre geleitet werden
was bei der schilder erkennung im
straßenverkehr katastrophale
konsequenzen haben könnte
kommt jetzt der krieg der kx und
salzgitter gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke und nur
so verpasst ihr nichts
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
dieses video ist in zusammenarbeit mit
der redaktion von ix entstanden das
fachmagazin informiert über alle
wegweisenden entwicklungen im it bereich
und am ende oder hierunter me und in der
video beschreibung könnt ihr euch eine
digitale ausgabe gratis sicher
künstliche intelligenz ist bereits
heutzutage aus zahlreichen bereichen
nicht mehr wegzudenken in der medizin
können bilderkennung algorithmen
beispielsweise dabei helfen epileptische
anfälle zu erkennen
auch bei der lager kommissionierung
spielt sie eine wichtige rolle ebenso im
energiesektor beispielsweise verlässt
man sich auf automatische alarme die
losgehen wenn sich windkraft
empfindliche vogelarten in der nähe von
windenergieanlagen herumtragen
teilweise werden die anlagen dann
komplett abgeschaltet vor allem aber
auch in der it sicherheit sind die
künstliche intelligenz und das
maschinelle lernen nicht mehr
wegzudenken
hier geht es vor allem darum angriffe zu
erkennen oder bereits komprimierte also
manipulierte systeme zu identifizieren
in der vergangenheit waren es vor allem
statische muster und regeln auf basis
der attika feindliche angriffe erkennen
sollte mittlerweile sind es neuronale
netzwerke oder andere techniken des
maschinellen lernens die eingesetzt
werden und oft bereits beim hersteller
trainiert werden doch auch beim kunden
selbst können solche systeme das normale
verhalten von programm und der
kommunikation im netzwerk erfahren
dadurch werden sie dann in die lage
versetzt bei abweichungen alarm
auszulösen angriffe werden somit also
automatisiert erkannt und bekämpft und
das bringt die it sicherheit enorm weit
nach vorne doch wie immer gibt es auch
hier ein aber denn auch eine künstliche
intelligenz ist nicht davor gefeit
ausgeprägt zu werden selbst
sicherheitssysteme können beispielsweise
durch vergiftete trainingsdaten
manipuliert werden das beispiel des
sogenannten base in spam filters
zeitliches genauer bei diesem statischen
verfahren handelte sich um einen
mechanismus der spam-mails blockiert mit
bereits vorhandenen mails wird es darauf
trainiert mails in der zukunft
klassifizieren zu können doch das kann
schief laufen wenn ein angreifer die
möglichkeit bekommt manipulierte mails
in den lernvorgang einzuschleusen so
kann das modell quasi nach den wünschen
des hackers vergiftet werden die spätere
erkennung läuft dann nach den
vorstellungen des angreifers ab eine
eindeutige schwachstelle durch die eine
künstliche intelligenz relativ einfach
ausgetrickst werden kann und es gibt
weitere möglichkeiten für angreifer um
zu verhindern dass malware erkannt wird
alleine schon ein wechsel des
dateiformats lässt es manchmal zu das ki
mechanismen ausgetrickst werden denn
neuronale netzwerke werden meist nur mit
ausführbaren excel-dateien trainiert
wenn ein bösartiges makro aber in einer
excel datei oder einen powershell skript
versteckt wird dann wird das oft nicht
als mal wer identifiziert eine weitere
methode besteht darin mal wer zu
verschlüsseln beziehungsweise zu packen
auch dieses bösartiger ergebnis wird von
den mechanismen meist nicht als solches
erkannt vor allem wenn das verschlüsseln
oder packen mit hilfe eines eher
unbekannten programms erfolgt ein
australisches forschungsteam hat erst im
vorherigen jahr eine alarmierende
warnung in diesem zusammenhang
herausgegeben demnach kann eine bekannte
malware ganz einfach als eine solche
verschleiert werden indem bestimmte
texte angehängt werden auch netzwerk
erkennungs werkzeuge die auffälligkeiten
in der kommunikation identifizieren
sollen sind vor angriffen nicht gefeit
denn bei dieser form des maschinellen
lernens wird im laufenden betrieb
gelernt was normal also auffällig ist in
der fachsprache ist von ansgar peiß
learning die rede auch hier können sich
angreifer einschleusen und dafür sorgen
dass manipulierter datenverkehr als
normal gelernt wird
um das zu verhindern werden produkte
ergänzt und zwar um erkennungs modelle
mit super weiße ring so soll verhindert
werden dass der datenverkehr von bereits
infizierten modellen als normal gelernt
wird hierbei werden die produkte direkt
beim hersteller trainiert und
vorab typische angriffs kommunikation
und malware zu erkennen und es gibt
einen weiteren wirklich innovativen
ansatz um angriffe auf ki zu verhindert
das ziel hierbei malware dateien soll
mit hilfe von neuronalen netzwerken
erkannt werden diese werden zu diesem
zweck mit unzähligen gutartigen dateien
und zudem auch mit millionen von malware
dateien trainiert wichtig hierbei ist
ein algorithmus der die eigenschaften
der daten ableitet fachleute sprechen in
diesem zusammenhang von der sogenannten
feature extraction die dann die eingangs
werte für ein neuronales netzwerk bilden
hier raus kommt ein mathematisches
modell das aus den eigenschaften von
neuen und unbekannten daten herausfinden
kann ob es sich um eine gutartige datei
oder aber um einen manipulativen angriff
handelt eine wirklich gute sache doch
hierbei gibt es einige herausforderungen
denn diese trainings art für ein
neuronales netzwerk ist nicht nur
äußerst rechten aufwendig sondern auch
sehr langwierig und so kann es schon mal
schnell einige wochen dauern bis das
netzwerk überhaupt trainiert ist und das
obwohl riesige rechnerkapazitäten
eingesetzt werden eine schnelle reaktion
auf neue angriffe ist somit nicht
möglich und so setzen viele hersteller
auf eine kombination aus neuronalen
netzwerken und anderen erkennungs
techniken trotz all dieser lücken
fachleute weltweit sind sich sicher dass
uns die künstliche intelligenz mit ihren
vielfältigen einsatzgebieten in der
zukunft um neue geschäftsmodelle neue
produkte und dienstleistungen sowie neue
berufsfelder bereichern wird die meisten
menschen nutzen in vielen bereichen
ihres alltags bereits heute techniken
der künstlichen intelligenz manchmal
vielleicht sogar ohne sich darüber im
klaren zu sein denken wir mal an siri
von apple an alexa von google oder
andere sprach steuerungssysteme um
sprache zu erkennen sind techniken aus
dem bereich der künstlichen intelligenz
notwendig und auch das bietet hackern
eine angriffsfläche sprachbefehle können
so verfremdet abgespielt werden dass sie
zwar für uns nicht mehr verständlich
sind jedoch aber für die kühlsysteme
diese reagieren darauf und handeln
dementsprechend von den usern
unbeabsichtigt werden somit also
bestellungen bei amazon oder anderen
shopping portalen ausgelöst oder aber
mal websites aufgerufen
auch bei spracherkennungssysteme sind
feature extraktion wichtig diese
extrahieren die relevanten eigenschaften
eines audiosignals umgeben diese dann an
ein neuronales netzwerk weiter angreifer
können das ausnutzen aus dem befehl
zurückrechnen welche features im
eingangssignal notwendig sind damit die
befehle erkannt werden so werden
geräusch erzeugt die wir menschen beim
besten willen nicht verstehen können
anders aber die ki system mit die die
manipulierten geräusche im sinne des
angreifers interpretieren ähnlich
funktioniert das auch bei der erkennung
von bildern der us-wissenschaftler ein
gut fellow hat das in einer studie
eindrucksvoll gezeigt es geht um das
bild eines pandas dass eine
bilderkennung sky mit einer sicherheit
von 57,7 prozent erkennt wenn ein
weiteres bild das für einen menschen nur
wie rauschen aussieht schwach über
dieses panda bild gelegt wird hat das
den folgenden effekt für uns menschen
bleibt das panda bild ein panda bild die
ki aber lässt sich durch die
überlagerung mit dem rauschen
manipulieren sie ist sich zu
unglaublichen 99,3 prozent sicher dass
es sich um das bild eines gebäudes
handelt völlig egal ob es sich um panda
oder um einen geboren handelt bei diesem
beispiel vielleicht schon
doch auch selbstfahrender autos nutzen
bild erkennungssysteme dazu haben
britische wissenschaftler innen und
wissenschaftler eine alarmierende studie
vorgelegt in ihren versuchen hatten sie
harmlos aussehende farbkleckse auf
normale verkehrsschilder gebracht mit
erschreckenden folgen denn so wurde
deren sind komplett ins gegenteil
verkehrt aus einem verkehrsschild dass
eine geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung von 80
kilometern pro stunde forderte wurde für
die bild erkennungssysteme ein
stoppschild und es gibt weitere
beispiele die deutlich machen dass nicht
nur sprach steuerungssysteme sondern
auch bild erkennungssysteme optimiert
werden müssen denn sonst drohen fatale
folgen die die sicherheit unserer
gesellschaft bedrohen gesichts
erkennungssysteme werden beispielsweise
eingesetzt um öffentliche plätze zu
überwachen doch versuche zeigten dass
sich diese sehr leicht austricksen
lassen unter anderem durch das tragen
von bunten brillen spezieller kleidung
oder bestimmten schwingt techniken so
wurden diese personen zum teil gar nicht
mehr oder als komplett anderen personen
erkannt ja ein riesiges problem dem sich
mittlerweile auch die forschung
angenommen hat sie tüftelt an techniken
um manipulative angriffe zu erkennen und
bilderkennung
verfahren zu optimieren doch sobald neue
verbesserte verfahren ausgereift sind
steigen auch die hacker ein und flügel
neue angriffstechniken aus einen
wettlauf ist also entbrannt ein krieg
der k der nach ansicht von fachleuten
auch noch einige zeit anhalten wird wenn
die technik auf beiden seiten die steckt
noch in den kinderschuhen doch es geht
noch weiter denn hacker haben längst
nicht nur als neues angriffsziel für
sich entdeckt sie nutzen künstliche
intelligenz mittlerweile auch für ihre
zwecke und setzen diese ein um
schwachstellen zu identifizieren oder
und klassische systeme anzugreifen mit
hilfe von ki basierenden methoden haben
angreifer hat deutlich bessere
möglichkeiten verwundbarkeiten
aufzuspüren als mit regelbasierten
system wie sie in der vergangenheit
angewandt wurden ein beispiel dafür
haben hacker vor zwei jahren auf dem
chaos communication congress
demonstriert hier ging es darum einen
geheimen pin code heraus zu finden mit
dem sich das hardware wallet für crypto
währung freischalten lässt das eingeben
des kos analysierten die hacker mit
hilfe von maschinellem lernen und nutzen
dafür die charakteristische strahlung
des eher schlecht abgeschirmten geräts
beim eingeben des codes auf dem touch
display wird die gedrückte taste ja kurz
farbig hinterlegt dazu notwendig die
kommunikation eben zwischen cpu und
display und genau diese kommunikation
konnte mit hilfe eines funkempfänger es
noch aus zwei metern abstand abgefangen
werden
diese abstrahlung analysierten die
hacker allerdings nicht manuell
stattdessen wurde eine tänzer flow
engine eingesetzt das ist ja die crm
software von google
die sich jeder herunterladen kann und
darauf programmieren darauf basiert
übrigens auf der youtube algorithmus sie
wird vor allem im bereich des
maschinellen lernens angewendet diese
konnte mit leichtigkeit die gedrückten
tasten und somit auch den geheimen pin
code ermitteln
mehr zum thema und anderen umfassend
recherchierten themen aus dem bereich
erfahrt ihr im fachmagazin die iks von
it-security über big data bis hin zu
embedded systems exklusiv für euch
klicks um zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
gibt es jetzt eine digitale ausgabe
gratis klickt dafür einfach hier auf den
link oder unten in die video
beschreibung es lohnt sich auf jeden
fall
und hier geht es weiter mit bedroht
künstliche intelligenz die menschheit
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
zwar diesen kanal bis dann klicks vom
science in future
bis dann bleibt dran